las autoridades ucranianas han informado
que durante el día de hoy continuarán a
intentar evacuar a aquellos civiles que
aún siguen atrapados en la planta de
acero de mariupol esta estratégica
ciudad desde el sur de ucrania que se
encuentra bajo control ruso por otra
parte también hay denuncias hechas por
el alcalde de melitópol siempre en el
sur de que habitantes de su ciudad
estarían siendo secuestrados continúa la
ofensiva rusa también en el este donde
nos encontramos en mi pro las sirenas
han vuelto a sonar en varias ocasiones
esta mañana y hay información de avances
rusos hacia las localidades lubianka
clamatos y se vieron dones que preocupa
también a esa orilla donde también el
avance está siendo lento pero sostenido
como ocurre en las guerras terrestres